>> A conditioned taste aversion can occur when an organism ingests something and
it makes them ill. For example, Susan here has a conditioned taste aversion to
Moo Shu Pork. So Susan, how does that make you feel?
[LAUGH]
>> Oh gosh, I feel I feel like I might want to vomit and I'm salivating and I
don't like it at all.
>> I'm sorry, I'll, I'll put it down.
>> Susan's nausea and sickness is paired with the sight, the smell and the taste
of the food. So from an evolutionary perspective, this makes sense. We should
try to avoid things in the future that have made us ill. So sorry, Susan that
was just a little payback for Tickles the snake.
>> I forgive you, Lauren.
>> Thanks.
>> Here we can see that condition taste aversion happens after only one trial.
That's different from classical conditioning, where we have repeated
presentations. For example, I got sick on Moo Shu Pork over ten years ago, and
as you can see today, I still can't stomach it. So, let's move away from the
Moo Shu Pork example. I'd like to finish this lesson on classical conditioning
by talking about a study that classically conditioned a sexual response to
women's black boots.